hello everyone i'm alana and i am
honored and very excited to have been
asked to announce the winners of
deepwell digital therapeutics first ever
inaugural mental health game jam the
event brought together a community of
global developers to create valuable
therapeutic experiences through games
depot's mental health game jam was
created to inspire games that can
entertain while simultaneously
addressing very serious very prevalent
issues like stress anxiety and
depression and foster support and
understanding for those dealing with
mental health challenges well there were
over a hundred games submitted with
teams competing for forty thousand
dollars in cash prizes and winners were
selected by a trusted panel of judges
from the games industry and medical
veterans as well and there were multiple
criteria ranging from gameplay to
treatment mechanics to furthering
understanding of mental health issues
which is really what this whole thing is
about and all of the entries i did play
majority of them were incredibly
impressive but without further ado let's
announce this year's winners
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so there you have it a huge
congratulations to all of the winners
and a very big thank you to everybody
who participated in this year's game jam
the games are so unique
so many moving experiences and while i
wish that i could have sat down to talk
to absolutely everybody that was a
little bit unrealistic so i did sit down
to chat to this year's grand prize
winner the team behind inner room i am
now joined by mateo and alberto who both
producers on the game uh a huge
congratulations first of all uh clearly
the judges really really love this
experience and so did i it's incredible
uh i wanted to ask some basic questions
i'm not going to throw you any dramatic
hard balls but what was the inspiration
for actually putting the game together
well um
basically the inspiration is the hard
time we all got on coffee time
and
like talking about the depression and
society is a really big challenge and we
thought that
really games should be fun but also
should
try to depict that
type of experiences in order to have
more empathy towards them
and also to try to think more about them
because sometimes we see
conditions like anxiety depression etc
something that it's outside of us
something alien and
and sometimes it's better that we try to
understand them in
different terms we think i think that
one thing you did exceptionally well is
actually make some of the gameplay
mundane you you kind of took fun out of
it which is you know it's still very
compelling to play but that's something
that is very kin akin to depression or
living with depression so i know that
you consulted with some professionals uh
before working on this like what was
their input and how did they drive uh
how you created the game
that's a really interesting question
because uh actually that's that's really
challenging because they're very
different point of views inside
of the medical viewpoint uh we talked
with psychologists uh with a more
conductive type of way of thing things
we also talked with
psychoanalysts and we also talked with
psychiatrists
so the whole
that whole mixture gave us like
different viewpoints and
from those viewpoints we created like
this experience because um even though
people from the medical world they have
different theories
in which they work
they also have common points and
they're
very very basic ideas one of them is the
psycho education
and many people really see therapy as
something horrible like the worst thing
that has ever happened to them in their
lives and it's actually the opposite no
so
it's important to to say that video
games are something extremely beautiful
extremely great
but uh they can be a really a good
bridge to to help to create awareness
about this type of subjects know so well
we try to aim to that did you draw from
your own personal experiences as well i
don't want to make you you know share
overly personal details if you aren't
comfortable but it does feel like a very
personal game especially some of the
family aspects
yeah of course
gabriel has just joined he he directed
the art in the project
and uh he's also my brother i'm really
proud to do a game like my brother and a
close friend
and yes i think that's a great question
also alana because making a video game
talking about depression implies that
first of all you don't talk about the
depression of others you start by your
own experiences
and in a team of developers that's
really interesting too because
we have to remember that video games
implies doing video games in place that
you do
you are creating something with people
that have very different disciplines
like programming is really different
from people that does art
and they come from different backgrounds
different way of seeing the work the
world and feel feel it
so
that was a really enriching experience
because
at some point in the discussion of
making the game we we began to talk a
lot about depression but everyone at the
same time was talking about their
experiences how they saw it
and
that's i think that's a very important
point that has to be balanced between
the how to make a research about
something with experts and academics and
documents and also how much of your own
vision your own experience your own
happiness and suffering of how you have
passed through that type of experiences
so for us that was a really really
strong point
if not put in those elements we would
have never had a like a strong position
about about it no i just want to ask
where did you start like what did this
idea actually start out as as you were
starting the game jam from all of your
perspectives everything begins in an
image
because i was working in the idea of
working with an isometric
view of a small room
because the idea of being captured in
this kind of cage that we we live in the
pandemic time is like a really good
trigger for for
talking about this kind of things of
course
then this image
develop
other images that begin to
to
construct some kind of chain so
a a machine in a way is a story it is a
tale a narrative of course uh
and then the isometric view begin with
this room with this guy
uh
in enclosure in this jail that is his
room in
this jail that is his job this jail that
is maybe this depressive a constant idea
that came to him
and another idea that appears at the
beginning of the game is the idea of uh
leave
with a hold in your space and this was a
metaphor of a lot of things trauma of
course but these hidden things that we
have to face
uh day by day
and and and the idea of the whole could
develop better i think because it's a
really really strong
idea that that became secondary in a
point
and and we
of course if we uh finish the game we
will
work about it i won't keep you for too
much longer but the last thing that i
wanted to ask is you guys seem to have
had a lot of success with game jams in
the past this is something that you're
obviously very good at the game's
awesome do you have any advice for
people who would like to participate in
game jams in the future yes of course a
lot of things
yeah there are a lot of advices
i think
a very strong advice is many times in
game gems
it's just an impression it's not uh uh
definitely true
but uh
i think when we when someone does a game
jam and many times is enters in a
challenging place where it has to create
dynamic mechanics and meaningful
narrative
but sometimes uh
in that challenge people forget about
the concept they are working on like not
only the experience of the mechanics
make an
immersive experience sometimes if you
lead a project with a concept behind it
a concept that is not led by the
mechanic but but an idea something that
has to be said opposition towards things
uh helps enormously to know where to cut
things
uh where to not
be so ambitious only with uh of course
like creating a super mechanic but
doesn't
have anything to say
uh in that short term
and and for us that has been like uh the
main
the main element of
being successful in game gems so in
closing again congratulations where can
people find all of you and find out what
else you're working on
well uh
right now we are working in the other
game
we made
we won the last uh
game gem and the cultural heritage game
and it's called puron machu it's about
the dangers of
cultural appropriation here in latin
america we have a lot of theft about
ancestral
pieces
sadly something that indiana jones has
done
[Laughter]
yeah
we are making also
a game about uh fake news
because it's a really interesting
subject
and really important in in the times
we're living do you have a twitter or a
page or anything where people can find
the stuff that you're all working on
we can follow
ours
right now we have like a bunch of people
working in this project we have a guy
pacha that is one of the studies that is
part of this particular game but mateo
and i have another
[Music]
video game
comic
a illustrator album and other kind of um
cultural material that we work the
studio is hermanos machia
magic brothers in english
and we can
you can follow us in
instagram instagram and facebook yeah
and you can see the products we have
been doing they are really crazy and fun
awesome uh thank you all so much for
joining me and i just want to say
congratulations again the game is is so
awesome and so heartfelt and i'm glad
that you made it so that we could all
play it
thank you thanks a lot
all right that is it for me today
everybody i will leave links in the
description below to where you can check
out all of the games made throughout the
month of may for the game jam and some
more information on deepwell as well
again congratulations thank you for
watching